[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum thanks for listening
if you're here for Larson Thompson and
you never listen to the podcast before I
hope you'll like it enough to say Hey
you know this guy doesn't suck and I'll
listen to the uh to more episodes I
think you'll really enjoy it and uh
Larson's fantastic and um you know we
talk about mental health and a lot of
fun stuff well speaking of Health
um
so I did this thing per Nuvo
uh it's a they do a scan on your body
I've talked about it before in fact I
posted about it and they don't pay me
it's on a paid advertisement or anything
like that
but they detect early stages of cancer
and everything except for like leukemia
so I did the test man I got the test
results back
and there was one thing that was
moderate risk that was in the yellow
that they said you should get more
imaging on this and it was in my pharynx
which is behind your larynx and is what
makes swallowing I think and like all
these things work
with your throat they found a cyst
and so I went to my ENT and the ENT
did a scope and saw the cyst and said
I think we should get more imaging
I want to make sure there's nothing
under the cyst
and I was just like I didn't I was like
okay all right
and then I went to Indiana
and in the back of my mind I was always
thinking of that cyst and like wow
tomorrow I could get bad information
that could be really scary and you know
of course like an idiot I read about all
these things and if you have cancer in
that area it's like
you have a five percent chance of living
it's just you're done
and so as the days I started thinking
about my mortality and I started
thinking well all right well what would
you do and I kind of came to terms with
like all right here's what you would do
and I sort of like you're gonna go visit
so and so you're gonna go here you're
gonna throw a party for your friends
it's like that song by uh Tim McGraw
Live Like You Were Dying Live Like You
Were Dying
uh but it's a great song people always
think about that stuff and if you just
like if you knew that you weren't going
to have long or that the person the
other person was gonna
what would you do and you always sings
and then you think about well why don't
you just do them now
and it's so true how it's like we have
the ability if you know most of us do or
some of us do if you have the ability
you know to do the things you want to do
because you just you just don't know I
could have got a Converse I could have
got a call and I just got this call is
why we are re-recording the intro
but um you know if I got a call and it
was the doctor and I was thinking
you know and if you said hey are you
sitting down
I mean I you know all these thoughts
coming here but anyway knock on wood
thank god
um God bless
um
I'm okay
so very glad you're okay yeah me too me
too man me too Life's too short and um
it could have been shorter you didn't
have to go skydiving rocky mountain
climbing on a 2.7 seconds on a bowling
food Manchu I love that song
I went
skydiving all right anyway uh hey our
socials are Ryan uh outside of you pod
on Twitter at side to be podcast on
Instagram and Facebook I had to think
about it for a second I know it's been a
while yeah we're on uh YouTube You're
gonna watch please subscribe it helps to
show immensely and write a review that
really gets us up on the charts also the
inside of you online store has amazing
new merch and I'm getting some really
cool stuff check this out Ryan
this guy made these
this
pretty much this sculpture of Mia's Lex
and brought it to a con and I was like
oh my gosh this is so cool
I was thinking about what would it cost
to like make like you know nine of these
I say nine because I'd keep on
um and I you know and I'd sell I put the
others on the inside of online store and
they're so hard to make and this is an
artist and so
you know I spent a lot of money to get
like these made and they're pretty
incredible and I'm gonna put them up
soon but there's only gonna be nine
they'll be a little pricey because
there's nine
and uh they'll be signed by me but
they're awesome and on the inside online
store there's tons of merch lexmus
scripts autograph for me and uh ship
keys that say Smallville from the show
and tons of other stuff uh tumblers I'm
getting new tumblers in a week or two
they're amazing my sister works for this
company PostNet
and uh they're making me all these cups
and I get a discount because I'm her
sister her brother I'm not her sister
um anyway also love you thank you for
the support join patreon.com inside of
you I'll get a shout out on the podcast
with your name you support the podcast
and you're the reason why I still do
this you keep the show going and um so
thank you for that and that's about it
Ryan you're doing all right I'm doing
good I'm I'm getting away too I'm going
uh or bachelor party weekend in
Scottsdale Arizona can you just go to a
bachelor party
you know someone just said that to me
and I can't think of what it was yeah it
was like
it was something like the last time you
were with those guys you like got too
drunk or something
that's my seizure story from uh that I
but that was like five years ago that
was like five years ago yeah but then
weren't you meeting with those people
again uh
uh I don't know I can't remember I can't
remember
but anyway you're traveling you're good
I'm traveling so I'm getting out of town
do you need it you like it you love it
you love it that's good so uh this uh
guy the guy who's marrying my sister uh
we're gonna hang I'm gonna hang out with
him and all his friends oh boy yeah oh
yeah oh man
um
all right let's just do it let's get
into this
um she's amazing she was so wonderful
she brought her mom on the podcast not
on the podcast but she's in the other
room laughing I could hear her and uh
she was awesome she was awesome her mom
was awesome what a great family
um
she's in Midnight Club she models she's
on Instagram follow her she's fun she's
beautiful she's cool that's the most
important thing her name is Larson
Thompson so let's get inside of Larson
Thompson it's my point of view
listening to inside of you
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience Larson
Larson Thompson is that your real name
yeah I've never met a Larson well it's
actually usually a last name but it was
my grandma's
it was my great grandma's last name with
an O
my parents are like we really like that
name
let's make it her first name and end it
with an e l a r s e n it's a cool name
you know what it sounds like Ryan tell
us put the mic to your mouth God's sakes
Larson sounds like a popular girl's name
like a popular in high school are you
going to Larson's party yeah I wasn't
invited
were you popular
just admit it Just Go With It Roll with
whatever you were I wasn't you were no
no let's just go with that way hey well
I didn't really get to
have the
normal high school experience I like
went through all of middle school but I
was like every day after school gone at
the dance studio didn't really get time
to like hang out with friends or ever go
to parties really high school I went out
my sophomore year
um so didn't really have the high school
experience was able to go to prom which
was I didn't I never went to high school
dance hold on a second hey is this is
she a little too like there's a spacing
on here is a little too she has too much
space
space name is name this TV show Larson
space the final frontier
These Are the Voyages of the
Star Wars track
it's okay you're all for one there'll be
more
no don't give me these I'm like I
us but when it comes
any type of references or anything like
that I just like go bring a blank yeah
go blank but you probably a reader so
you remember yeah I do read you do I
like dirty what do you read
um you know I read a lot of like self
self growth books a lot of faith books I
like them just in ways to grow as a
person as an individual and in my crafts
are you more spiritual you think yeah
I'm pretty spiritual
um I grew up Christian and you know now
I have my own personal relationship with
God and walk with him and you know it's
really a part of who I am it's what
keeps me grounded and if I'm really just
thankful for it wow yeah
see you're 22. 22. you know
again I what I like about this is be I
usually interview people
mid 30s 40s 50s older yeah and so you
have people that have really lived a
little they've had a lot of experiences
they've had a lot of issues at facing
adversity and depression so I wanted to
talk to someone
it that's obviously bright and cheerful
and awesome and talented but someone
that was younger to get a perspective
from that and what you're starting to go
through what you're starting to learn
about yourself what you're starting to
learn about others the industry so I
want to get into all that because I
think that's really cool and it's it's a
perspective I remember but it was
different time it was a different time
it was uh you know it just was it was
different yeah it's not like I'm 80 but
it was different
um but childhood was good for you yeah
childhood was really good for me I'm
because your mom's in the other room
yeah my mom's in the other room my
parents oh she was a joy she is really a
joy they are my best friends like I'm so
close with my parents I'm very thankful
and fortunate for that
um just their support system the way
that they've you know through their
wisdom and the way that they've you know
gone through struggles and battles and
the way they've raised me
um as a teenager starting in the
industry so young I mean I started at
four oh I started dancing at four and
then began working in the industry
around 12
that's crazy now is it something that
Elizabeth your mom pushed you into was
she like a mommy dearest chick we were
talking about that back there and she
made a joke kidding but I'm wondering
was she kind of like I want you to do
this I want you you're so beautiful
Thompson you need to do this no so
actually
I guess like I my my aunt was in the
Olympics as a gymnast and my mom was
like I always had this desire what's her
name Julian McNamara 1984
um gold medalist for what
um bars she's like what yeah she's
incredible
how old is she now
she's
50 58. oh she's still young yeah she's
young that's young yeah right it's funny
because my aunt and I look like twins
and my cousin my aunt's daughter my mom
look like twins it's very weird
but everyone's like you look just like
your aunt but um I think my mom grew up
in that
um kind of environment with my aunt
leaving when my mom was like 12 years
old
um and so my mom and I grew up very very
close because of that and
and I I had this desire for dance I
never really took it seriously about the
age of 10 and the studio owners I would
take it seriously who would take it I
don't take it seriously at my age yes I
know
I mean you can't I think that's how you
get through things yeah no no exactly
and I think the studio owners were
coming up to my mom being like we don't
think Larson dances for Larson she's you
know all over the place she has too much
energy definitely like ADHD there's
something going on here yeah and so my
mom was like well you know if you're not
you know she'll she'll prove you wrong
and my mom was just like Larson like
where do you want to take this like do
you want to take this seriously like is
dance
um you know a profession that you want
to go into because you can start very
very young and dance and I was like I
mean yeah so I they started driving me
to La I started meeting all the
choreographers at Millennium dance
Comics because you grew up in Thousand
Oaks we still live there same house yep
same holy [__] are your parents still
married yes they are oh how many years
26 years
it's funny because my parents divorced
after 27.
but you know that was you know it
happened when I was a little bit older
so it was still very difficult not
because I really cared but but because I
had to I I didn't realize I knew they
shouldn't be together okay I knew that
it was just like oil and vinegar yeah
you know what this wasn't right you know
they fought this passive aggression
there was a mutual respect after a while
I think they really loved each other
when they were younger but my mom's more
of more of a uh not ostentatious oh she
could be that if she had money but um
more of uh what's the word when you're
just like all over the place flamboyant
and uh attention [__] oh [__] what no
well I could be an attention [__] I'm
like you know you want to be the center
of attention it wasn't that I didn't
mean a [__] yeah no I know what you
mean yeah yeah an attention uh yeah
loves attention
Jason don't edit that out I like it
um
okay this is good but my parents when
they divorced I was like oh of course it
wasn't a shock to me my mother she'd
call me at three in the morning while I
was just starting my career yeah I mean
not starting my career but like you got
the one of the biggest opportunities in
my life if I recall it's when
they divorced right when Smallville
started and so I'm trying to you know
it's a it's a big thing to handle and
might try to be good and stress and all
that stuff and they got divorced but she
would call me at three in the morning I
can't do it I can't I can't live my life
and really tough so divorce can be
incredibly tough 100 and I don't yeah
and especially if you're a young kid
whether you like it or not you're going
to have issues later yeah that you have
to work on yeah but you
thank God luckily came from an unbroken
family you know so what's that like
you know I think it's you know I don't
think you know behind closed doors no
family's perfect none of us are perfect
individuals
um and so it's like I one thing of the
lesson I've learned from my parents is
like marriage is not not easy you know
it's very hard I see my parents struggle
in the challenges they have but you know
they fight for their marriage you know
my dad and my mom they fight for it and
I think that's what I admire most about
them is
uh you know the way that they still
spend time together and they go and take
trips to you know re-establish their
love and to connect and they talk yeah
they talk a lot I come from a very
um vulnerable emotional family we don't
hide yeah does Elizabeth cry a lot
Elizabeth does cry a lot what does she
cry at
cries when our kids are in pain she
cries
um when life is just hard what pain have
you been in that she's cried about
one that you think of right away
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs look if you're
thinking of giving you therapy a try
better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside inside
of you is brought to you by home Chef
look we make thousands of decisions
every single day and by the end of the
day the last decision we want to worry
about is what is for dinner
I mean I
I'm I gotta get somebody in my life here
Ryan I'm alone
and it's especially hard so what do I
want to do I want to order food all the
time
this is where home Chef comes in Ryan
say goodbye to meal planning recipe
induce stress last minute grocery store
runs and let home Chef bring simple
delicious home-cooked meals right to
your door
how is that how about going not going
anywhere and somebody delivering you
everything to make the perfect meal and
that means the exact amount of
ingredients you need the exact amount of
this that you don't have to worry about
buying you know too much and having it
sit in your fridge and rot and spend
more money it's all there for you it's
simple I do it
it's so easy
um home Chef makes your nightly routine
easier and more exciting with a wide
selection of delicious meals that arrive
at your doorstep in the form of fresh
perfectly pre-portioned ingredients and
an easy to follow recipe card with 30
unique and flavorful Chef curated meal
options available each week home Chef
ensures your taste buds will never get
bored home Chef will recommend meals
based on your selected preferences with
plenty of menu options to fit any
dietary needs don't have time to cook
have a hot delicious meal on the table
in a snap with quick Solutions like
their 15-minute recipes microwave meals
and oven ready options that save you
time and effort in the kitchen plus
cleanup is a breeze I just love this
company I love what they do and you're
getting delicious meals that are right
there for your cooking so you know a lot
of times when you get these meals that
are already prepared
they've been sitting around you get them
you know you go to work and you get
there they've been there for four hours
in like ice or whatever but it just
seems kind of you know it's sort of
artificial it feels like you don't
really want to eat it because it's not
you know usually when you order food at
a restaurant you get it and you eat it
it's hot it's there so you don't you
know you have to heat up crap
and this is just like brought to you and
you cook it
and all this stuff is there for you you
don't it's so easy you can be done in 15
minutes and you've got a hot cooked meal
that you've made you can feel
accomplished because that's what it's
all about right fulfillment
um if you have specific dietary needs
explore carbon calorie conscious menu
items customize your protein swap for
vegetarian friendly options
um what I loved it was the perfect
amount of food I mean I usually eat all
of them and if not I know that it's just
one heat up if I want to have leftovers
um I love chicken it's delicious uh
and it was easy to make I mean I had a
skillet and uh oh it says oh just add
this okay it's all pre-portioned or it's
all it's it's so easy guys home Chef for
a limited time only go to homechef.com
inside for 75 off your first box you
can't lose with that 75 off your first
box give this a shot again go to
homechef.com inside for 75 off
something that really hurt you or you
were really sad and she felt your pain
[Music]
was it a breakup
was it a
I think what what where my mom gets the
most frustrated and angry is when people
like my mom is like the mama bear where
like when people online come at me and
they don't know who I am that really
affects her and they are where I'm very
much like I brush it off and I'm like
hey you know what like I'm not gonna let
this affect me I am who I am I know who
I am these people don't know me but my
mom is the mama bear where she's like I
can't believe they would say that about
you and it gets her really frustrated
and I'm like Mom it's okay we don't know
them they're probably behind a computer
screen just like trolls yes just like
taking out their own insecurities or
things that they're facing and putting
it onto somebody else yeah every once in
a while I'll read a comment like you
know very few but like yeah he wasn't
the best Lex you know I'm just kidding
you are the Giant's a joke I mean it's a
joke but Ryan
um how many guests have come in here
over the years
and said I don't read
reviews I don't look at critics a lot of
them have said that right yeah yeah
because I think it's a healthy thing
right I know but it's something also
that feedery go and makes you feel like
you're worthy and then it's sometimes
crushes your ego makes you feel like
[__] so it's better to not and just kind
of stay balanced I guess but
I I'm one that sometimes likes I I make
the mistake of thinking something that I
did was really good or I was really good
and they're gonna notice me and that's a
mistake because then you're like what
how could you think this way and then
that it's not a good feeling yeah so all
I will suggest to you is definitely
don't believe what you're reading
especially for people that don't know
you and try to take things with a grain
of salt or try to stay away from that
stuff and just do the best because
you'll be it will interfere in your life
yeah no I find
[Music]
three years ago
um I had been doing it since I was kid
kind of took a break and then was like I
want to do this for real now and I still
am like I can't stand watching myself I
have a weird thing you hear that a lot
with actors like it's very hard for me
because I myself I'm my biggest crib are
you looking at your face no never mind
I'm just looking at like acting my
acting all right so you you're okay
looking at yourself yeah like you're
like I'm pretty I'm not worried about
that is that what you're saying I mean
no but it's a good thing it's good to
know that's a I'm telling you ninety
percent of actors don't like watching
themselves because they're like oh God
my nose oh look at the bags
what's very interesting is in acting
even if I like I feel like I've talked
to a lot of people that are very aware
of how they're they look when they're
like crying or if they're screaming when
I'm acting I could care if I look
ugly I'm like great good I was in it
that was it I could care less if there's
like tears and I'm like no snot coming
down trust the director yes I'm like
this is acting this is what it is like
you're not in real life like worried
about like snot coming down your nose
and being like have you had those
moments where you're crying like that
yeah most recently I was working on a
film called horoscope with so many
pictures I just got back from it
um so I was there for three months in
Belgrade Serbia who's in that um Jacob
battle on from Spider-Man
um Harriet Slater
who else
umbrella Gonzalez yeah there's seven
it's an ensemble cast there's seven of
us all leads and scary scary movie Yes
deals with horoscopes and a lot of what
you know this generation is very into
horoscopes these days and I think it
will do there's also like a sense of
entertainment to it
um
I think it will do really well and I'm
very excited about it it comes out in
2023 in theaters so great you'll have to
email me and let me know so Ryan and I
can go see it yeah let's go right I'll
go but wait a minute you were about to
tell me something that happened on that
side oh yeah yeah so
it's I think this is why I love horror
the most I think it's the most wait a
minute you like horror the most I think
I walk around you well look at us look
around you
look up here
it's a little rubber band yeah Elizabeth
probably knows it I never know yeah none
of us we didn't catch on so late yeah
all right go ahead
sorry no I think I love it because it's
the most I think the most challenging
genre
um yeah especially for me that's just
how I feel but putting yourself in these
like most the most unrealistic like
circumstances and truly believing it and
like I had a scene I had to do I can't
like share the scene but like something
that was so just like horrible yeah
something that's just so it's not gonna
happen so unrealistic but like truly
believing it and that was where it's
like you have like five cameramen that
are just like Soundstream too or
whatever no we weren't on a green screen
this is a real creature or whatever
don't say anything stop yeah
um but to like be looking at people like
you know cough like doing a little thing
like that or just adjusting and moving
and that's you're looking and trying to
believe what you're saying it's well not
only that
but you're at the beginning of your
career so everything's new so yeah you
being on set with all the crew and all
the cast and the producers and the
director and they're all watching you
and they're like
um
um Larson are you I forgot your name for
a second no no I'm kidding because I was
going to say Laura Lars because I was
thinking son because that was your
grandma's spelling of her yeah no and
they're like okay Larson Act
and you gotta start crying and be
emotional and the most important thing
you have to do which you probably don't
have a lot of experience doing is really
trusting yourself yeah which that never
I've done stuff where I just I'm like I
don't I don't I don't know and some the
first take they're like okay then he's
it needs to be a little big we need to
see more emotion second take okay and by
the fifth take I get there yeah because
there's no way you're gonna get there in
the first take with those emotions
totally totally I mean she's crying
she's crying keep rolling guys keep
rolling fix the snot on her nose and
then I want to get that because that's
ridiculous okay good let's distracted
two where I'll just be like hey I'm
gonna need like you call Action give me
a few seconds I'm gonna like scream and
get their like emotionally you have your
things to do yeah I do my things well I
do I will I'll sit there and I go come
on God
and I'll yell at myself and I go come on
dude let's go you know just something
I've seen like I worked with Jesse
Eisenberg and uh the other Lex Luthor I
love him he was great to work with wow
and what he does before every take he
just jumps up and down
turns in circles turns in circles turns
in circles wow yeah and I you know if
you have to be kind of like if I'm
playing a drugged up or emotional
sometimes I'll spin around I'll do
something whatever it takes to get me
going exactly and it's like it's like
your head that
that's where I'll go like
like they're like we need you I'm like
all right I'm up I'm I'm here I'm ready
just to like get me out of my head and
stop thinking get my heart going or
something that good yeah yeah you're
learning the tricks of the trade I guess
I mean have you ever just felt like you
haven't you didn't get it you just
couldn't pull it out like it's okay it's
fine but you're like it's not great yeah
and I I being so hard on myself and
being a perfectionist I struggle with
that a lot where I like come out of it
and be like gosh I could have done
better and I'm like so grateful this the
film that I just did I there was this
one scene that I
I had so much going on that day and
there was this it was a pretty emotional
scene and I was I was like gosh I just I
walked out of there and was like I could
have done better and that's like the
worst feeling I feel like I've done that
very much and then next thing you know
they're like we need to catch some more
we didn't get to catch for that scene
um everything we wanted to get so we're
gonna we're gonna cover it again and I
was like yeah yes like it was the best
feeling because I was like yes I get
another go at it and I just felt so much
you know I'll tell you a story even the
best the biggest stars in the world go
through this hmm
um
sliced alone
icon
worked with him in Guardians three
that's coming out in gardens two and
he's
a hero that when you meet him you're
like
funny as hell sign my Rambo lunchbox
just epic and you know what he says to
him he says he's signing my lunch boxes
you got a lunch box
I go yeah I guess how old are you
say you little love for a lunch box okay
freaking thermos in here what are you
doing you know and I was like yeah yeah
and he laughed he was joking around but
a joy to work with
I mean he would crack jokes but there
was one scene we did and he has this
line
he just
it was fine yeah I watched it go they
got it they got it
but
he later called the director and say you
know look I love to do it again I love
to just shoot my close-up again I think
I could do a better job
I think I could do it better
and the first thing we woke up the next
morning we went to set for his close-up
just to get that and did it again for
sly
and he was better wow so it doesn't just
happen now if I called and said hey I
think I could do better no we're not
losing money we're not losing money on
you Rosenbach we've already lost money
on your performance last day
but
that should make everybody feel good
knowing yeah it's it's it's not it's not
an easy job to make things seem real
believable yeah you know how many times
you watch a movie go that was her
reaction like we laugh about it but
um the guy in Smallville who's a really
good actor there's a scene where a body
drops out of a closet
and his responses
damn
who's that
we laugh about all the time but he's
like damn
who's that
what's very weird
he's a dead body like
this podcast is brought to you by Dove
men plus care guys do you get distracted
during the day thinking about your
underarm sweating or itching or emitting
an odor oh do those thoughts keep you
from showing care when it counts new and
improved Dove men plus care
antiperspirant with 72 hours sweat and
odor protection and one quarter
moisturizing cream helps you forget
about your underarms so you can be
present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant or ever personal
care products are sold this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection no but what's very
interesting is like I watch movies with
my brother who is just
doesn't understand acting you know could
look at anything and be like he doesn't
think no and it's like
it's like actor when I like watch movies
now I can point out like continuity
things and I'm like I
because I'll be like I was not no and
now with him I watch them I'm like did
you notice that he's like no I'm like
okay it's just an actor thing I guess
you know that's some perspective right
there what you just said no one really
we haven't talked about
it's such a different world when you you
as someone who's in the profession it's
what you do for a living and you're
watching something you're critical of
everyone I saw a camera Shadow I think I
saw them was that the mic yeah yeah oh
exactly oh wait a minute her hair wasn't
like that
and you go to the Midwest and like man
that movie was awesome Yes man I go you
didn't notice this or this no I thought
she was awesome
so we're so hard on ourselves that I'm
coming to believe I'm realizing
that even if I'm not what I think I
should be it's probably gonna be fine
yes they're probably gonna go yeah it
was fine it's good yeah
I'm always trying to be great great how
do I be the greatest in every line but
in reality
ninety percent of the world 98 of the
world that's not in Hollywood 100
they're like
they're okay they're okay with a lot of
the stuff that we notice that we don't
like exactly like we watched a movie
last night horror movie The Prodigy it's
this kid he played Georgie and it yeah
great little actor yeah he was fantastic
and I thought the movie was okay it
wasn't bad yeah you know I recommend it
it's not great yeah but there was a
scene
where they go to this doctor
and they play a tape because she
recorded her son speaking in a different
language
and she goes um oh can I can I keep this
and the mother's like yeah
and the next scene she takes it to this
guy the next scene is the guy
talking about oh that was a Hungarian
language which is fine okay you speak
Hungarian great I believe that
and then he gets this whole thing like I
think what he's suffering from is
perhaps this and tells the whole story
in one monologue like what we need to
know as an audience instead of letting
us learn things like thinking we need to
tell the audience and it pissed me off
so much and my friend Rob who is the
lead guitarist of my band sunspin throw
it out there I know same shameful listen
Shameless uh he helps me in vocabulary
um I looked at Rob after this I really
like that movie I go what about the
yeah I didn't I don't know I didn't care
about that
kind of helped me kind of figure it out
I'm like [__] yeah do you say the F word
I don't but
my mom died my mom cursed like a sailor
do you say f
no I say like go ahead fudge I see like
Frick and crap
um you know I try not to swear I really
do I I have a friend his name is John
heater and I laugh at him not because
he's Mormon
um I love Mormons they're fine people
great people in fact
um monogamists
um a lot of great stuff
but John he doesn't swear
and someone goes oh gosh that was effed
it's like dude was that his d
at first they laughed but then I started
doing it so now I do that because I
think it's funnier yeah and it's like
instead of saying F I just get yeah the
f word I just say
F
freaking f
I like saying Frick like frick frick
look it feels good but it's funny
because the first time I ever said the f
word was in a self tape like four years
ago were you embarrassed to say it no it
like felt good effing felt good that
would have been genius it felt good you
know it was like it had never come out
of my mouth and it was just like
dang all right
did you when you were younger was there
any
was there any moments in your life so
far because I know you're young I know
you haven't lived
I mean you've lived but yeah you know
live lived you haven't lived you need to
live girl there's so much life ahead of
you but was there a moment like
growing up where you're sort of not a
good person or not a good girl or maybe
going through a tough's time or maybe
kind of mean at times and then feel bad
about it later and maybe effed I mean
not f'd but you said the f word yeah
um
was there a time where your mom was like
Hey Thompson or
Lars and I want to say Thompson Larson
Larson
yeah you know is that what's going on
probably around the age of 14. I was
going through a a little bit of a
rebellious
Elias I was just very on
on edge very
very hard to deal with hormonal yes very
hormonal and it was also right at the
time that I kind of made the transition
from dance into modeling and I was like
kind of heartbroken to kind of be
leaving dance in that industry
and that was always like an outfit
outlet for me when I was depressed when
I was sad or felt anxiety I would
literally go to the studio and just like
dance forget about everything for hours
that's what that is exercise
you escape yeah yeah
and it was my escape and so I feel like
I had an injury and so that's most of
the reason why I kind of had to pause on
Dance for a while with my neck and it
was that surgery no I didn't but it was
actually two neck surgeries really yeah
please Sports my whole life I'm always
in pain it's it's life it's it's just I
don't know okay people have pain yeah
not like me but go on yeah and I and I
still like struggle with it I did my own
stunts this is kind of I learned my
lesson yeah I do too yeah and I just
basically messed up my ligaments a disc
one of my discs got an epidural did you
yeah yeah I know those yeah they put you
to sleep for the injection uh-huh I
liked it
it was it was really cool actually
people are scared to four one two out
yeah you know what's funny is people who
say
ah when they put you to sleep are you
afraid you're gonna die I'm like I won't
know yeah I'll be dead it's true I'll
fall asleep and I'll die that's the best
way to go if that happens God forbid all
right it's better to get hit by a car
and living through it yeah maybe you
know what's very interesting yeah what
redheads we take double the anesthesia
what yes are you aliens I guess so
double the anesthesia no no kidding and
this this one I was talking to the other
day she's a natural redhead her hair is
black now she has to tell him before or
hear her whoever is doing her um
anesthesia like I'm I'm a natural
redhead and then they know I gotta up
the dosage really isn't that wild uh
yeah it is wild never heard that have
you heard that yeah
but let me tell you something I I don't
do drugs
um I barely drink uh but whenever I have
to have an epidural and they put me to
sleep
can't wait hmm it's it's like a weird
addiction it's like I don't go go get
them every day but like you know once
every eight months sometimes you know
whatever sometimes a couple in a year
yeah but when I go that morning I'm like
the anesthesiologist comes over doctor
[__] you not krakorikian
wears a bandana kind of hippie dude I'm
like listen Dr Krikorian
I am
and I do this every time I go you know I
don't do any drugs you know I I barely
drink
this is like my only time to really feel
good if not for you know
for and what I'm saying to you is I
don't I don't want to be injected with
this stuff
and then fall immediately to sleep let
me enjoy it for a few minutes
let me just enjoy it and lie here and
feel good for a few minutes and he goes
absolutely
so he does it little by little so I can
kind of enjoy it wow I mean it's not
here's the funny thing
I wake up and I'm like oh yeah I'm just
groggy
and he comes over and I go dude
he said you're gonna let me feel it for
a few minutes he goes I did
you don't remember filming yourself on
your phone I go I looked at my phone it
was like three minutes hey what's going
on Hey listen to this joke and the
talking to all the nurses and laughing
and I'm like oh my Lord
I don't know no recollection of anything
enough that is the craziest part for me
is when I wake up and I'm like we're
done like how long was that do you still
get them yeah I still get
um epidurals for my neck I'm like about
to go in in January is your doctor Dr
Port no Dr Bajaj
sounds fancy yeah
where's he at in Beverly Hills no in
Marina del Rey um you said that
I think she did didn't she no I can't
run it back okay let's rewind this tape
can we rewind live we're not live
um you've done some cool stuff like I
read about this I was like you you're
choreographed you choreographed a
YouTube video that went viral viral
receiving four million views in 2016.
um you were 15.
and then later that year
you choreographed another YouTube video
for Run the World which I think is
Beyonce yeah it doesn't say here
received 8 million views
how the hell what
there's a lot of build up
there's a lot of Dramatics well I'm just
like I I look because I think I look at
15 and I'm like
you know I'm like oh my god what
happened in my pants you know oh my God
what am I doing uh I didn't know what I
was 15. I had no maturity I didn't I was
just like no brain your frontal cortex
or sorry it's not formed
you don't think as the things you think
of later and but you're moving at 15 and
you're did you what how did that happen
I mean how did you say this is what I'm
gonna do is it was your idea this is
what happened so my friend Taylor and I
you're Swift no I wish
love her
my friend Taylor and I we had been
working with a choreographer named
Janelle genestra and we started we had
this idea where like there's so many
Dance videos out there where people are
you know we're in class it started
that's when all the Social Media stuff
kind of started pumping around like when
I was like 13 everyone was filming their
classes now putting them up on YouTube
and it was just like gaining a lot of
traction and our choreographer Janelle
and Taylor and I were like okay how can
we make this different and she was like
why don't we start doing dance concept
videos let's tell a story through dance
and I'm like that's a great idea let's
do it let's have a message behind each
one and let's go for it and so the first
one we did
it was really just for fun the two of us
we called ourselves the fraternal twins
uh we kind of looked a little bit
similar and she did she needed less
anesthesia
[Music]
all right go ahead go on
and we filmed the first one and we it
was to IDF with you and what's that mean
um I don't Frick with you
oh so you could
print him that [__] but you can't say it
huh
is I grew up dancing to I look back at
like videos on YouTube when I was like
12 dancing to the most like crazy music
but at that time in dance like I never
listened to the lyrics because every
move for us is on the Beats so I look
back at like videos and what 12 dancing
to the most like insane songs and I'm
like no wonder in the comments people
are like why do you have a 12 year old
dancing to this
makes sense sometimes I've seen stuff
like that I'm like they're letting their
kids listen to this music yeah yes well
guess what it was the same thing when I
was younger I was listening to two Live
Crew everybody say hey I won't say it
but they said some gnarly [__] and uh
listening to NWA
freak the police coming down with
authority
it's totally it and I would beat box
hey
that's a top sound
okay
oh all right
um so then we did this the one for
Beyonce Run the World and that one was
just about women empowerment and that
was one of my favorite ones just the
message behind it and it just we went to
sleep and I swear it was like we woke up
and there was like three million views
and we were like
wait what like what but how do people
even like
I put some funny ass stuff up yeah and
I'm like but I'm like thank you yeah but
I look I'm like this is funny
and for some reason I just I guess I
don't have did you already have a lot of
followers from the first video we kind
of already had like a fan base that one
kind of grew over time like within a
week it was just like
whoa this is crazy and like Good Morning
America and we have these people
reaching out to us to like come on the
show and we're like wait what this is
just nuts did you get any money for all
the views so it wasn't on my channel
um split it with you well I actually
don't know if those videos were
monetized because 4 million get you some
money these days yeah four million you
probably would have gotten fifteen
thousand dollars twenty thousand dollars
for that video Yeah crazy right did
Beyonce call you or message you she
posted us on Twitter
and like put up our video and I think
that's how that one kind of sparked she
loved it she sent it out and boom yeah
and that started getting you some
attention yeah and that's kind of and
you're dancing I need to watch this we
need to go watch this yeah are you are
you great in this
is it pretty cool I yeah you should
watch it it's very it's very funny
because people are always like Larson
you're this very like
you know soft-spoken individuals yeah
kind of just like you know and then you
you dance and it's like this Beast comes
out it's like fire we don't even
recognize you I'm like yeah you know
that's where that passion comes out yeah
100 do you still dance yeah I still
dance now and it's fun for fun and it's
also with you know modeling I'm able to
incorporate my dance into a lot of the
projects I work on they find out I'm a
dancer and then they're like oh well can
you hit some moves for us and I'm like
sure let me just
could you do a Black Swan kind of movie
I would love to could you do it yeah you
could easily do that yeah no problem
yeah that's a big thing like if there's
a role and you're an actress and there's
dancing you have a good shot at it
I hope so that would be like the dream
right
that would be great you got to be
telling your manager to look for [__]
like that I guess there's not a lot of
dance well there are there are more
musicals and things like that you should
be up for it you auditioned for anything
not really not really musicals no no I
need to get on that
you're married yeah we need to make a
call after this I think so I think so
too um you were featured in Pink's
beautiful trauma how is Pink
she was incredible so I played pink in
her video beautiful trauma and she I
didn't get the chance to meet her we
were like over face time and it was very
cool to be able to collaborate with her
she was I think on tour at the time so
she was like helping us film this video
and she's overseas doing her thing and
being amazing and the choreographers RJ
and Nick were you know extremely
talented they had this vision and it was
a very cool part to play it was like
back in like the 60s and she's like
beautiful and the trauma and kind of
talk about like Perfection and all these
things yeah kind of that's where I began
to start loving you know acting was
through dance and all these things any
you know anytime I'm able to like
perform and entertain people it's that's
where I like Thrive starting so young
entertaining and dance getting thrown up
on a stage dancing for X Factor in it
being live and having to nail all over
so nervous and like having to nail your
choreo realizing like this is live girl
also like did you mess up at all no
thank God because that would have been
really bad you know
do you ever mess up yes okay because
yeah you're gonna do a lot more of that
yes we all mess up 100 you knew how to
deal with you're like okay I messed up
yes yes you can't get down you have to
just keep going you're getting more
takes exactly yeah
you go no but that's what's very
interesting when I began acting and talk
about like self tapes now that being so
big being in the room it was very much
like it was like one shot and that was
it then when like I kind of went from
this dance into from what I've been
taught at such a young age everything
being perfect because in dance there is
no you obviously you're gonna mess up
but like you're gonna get in trouble by
your choreographer it's gonna be a big
ordeal like messing up is not allowed so
when I got into acting
I'd get a script and I thought
everything had to be perfect so like my
dog or somebody would bark or the door
would open and I'd hear like a Creak and
I'm like oh can I redo it yes I'd be
like I gotta redo it I don't and now I'm
like no those this is like what happens
in life this is real so if my dog barks
and I can play with it then I'm gonna go
ahead and and make it work but like it's
very interesting coming from that
perfectionism and dance and realizing
like let that all go into acting you
know it's very
very interesting I did a self tape yeah
not too long ago it's one of the few
self tapes I've done in recent history
in recent times
um and I was doing it and I had somebody
reading with me and my friend Deneen
she had a couple drinks
from some soccer thing that they were
watching and they came back to my house
and we're hanging out we're gonna order
some food and she was in the uh in the
kitchen she knew I was doing the tape
and in my audition tape I thought it was
so good that I'm not doing another tag
and you could hear her go ma and
immediately here
yeah Tom told her to judge her boyfriend
because she's about to start talking she
goes uh
and you hear and I go nope
it was a comedy at least so let him
laugh let him go what the hell was that
it was loud and I was like you know
tough [__] I'm not doing it again oh my
guess what you booked it no I didn't
did not get the part but you know the
reason it was it was it was funny
because when I read it I go They're
gonna go for like a a big dude like uh
Ethan Supply like a you know big strong
beer to kind of guy who could be a coach
of a team and I was like I go um I don't
know I could be I just said I'm gonna
try because I like it yeah I tried it
and they said yeah I just we just want a
bigger guy and a that's in our mind I'm
like fine
that rejection yeah you have to I'm
totally cool with rejection yes now it's
taken a long time but I'm I'm cool with
it I'm cool with it I get over it
quickly it's not something that's easy
yeah um it took me a long time your ego
gets in the way and you're like what's
wrong with me what what's wrong
totally yeah
I think there's so many pieces to the
puzzle when it comes to
a role you know what I mean like that's
where
facing rejection I think is you gotta
know how to deal with it and brush it
off because it's like if it's not your
role it's not meant for you then it's
it's just not meant to be there will be
another one around the corner that's for
you and design for you like there's so
much that goes into it with the writers
and everything where I learn not to take
it personally at a young age like
there's so much that goes into it it's
not just like the one casting director
that's like we love you and then I get
my hopes up and then I'm like no it goes
to like many many other people many
other people you know
um
by the way you're really articulate
you're very like uh what's the word she
you handle yourself really well like for
someone like you know you're you're not
but you have like maybe an old soul
I feel like I have an old idea but you
seem like you're definitely more mature
than I am by far
I don't know if your mom is but um right
Elizabeth
um but no you are you handle yourself
really well and it's not a contest
anything it's a like I look up to you
you know I do
um but you by the way about dance I'll
say this quickly yeah it's rhetorical
you don't you don't have to respond and
you've talked about it yeah but the one
thing I do regret in in theater when I
train at the theater and yeah in college
all through college is uh I didn't take
a dance class and I see how much dance
can really help with movement as an
actor and this
um I didn't but
I can sort of dance without having to
take that sort of dance yeah I mean I
have fun and I can move a little bit and
it's funny and whatever but I I could
see how really intense dance and focus
and that sort of thing can really help
you as an actress yes I totally 100 has
and modeling with movement and being
able to pose dance has been extremely
beneficial
body language and all that
all that you know yeah how comfortable
in your body it's very important so I'm
thankful for dance in so many ways I
yeah you also I I'm just we're gonna end
with the dancing stuff We're not gonna
end with the dances I gotta call a
couple other things like his Midnight
Club and working with my boy Mike
Flanagan and all that [__] we'll get
into a little bit but you were a backup
dancer also for Christina Aguilera Janet
Jack and I will era
Chicago
I I missed like last night I go
I was like
is Melissa uh Eskridge is she uh is she
straight my friend goes uh it's
Etheridge
and then I messed up someone else badly
I was like the name I just I'm not good
I don't know same but Katy Perry pink
you said pink
were they all be honest yeah be honest
out of those three you don't have to
tell me the one there was there one that
you're like
she's got she's a little attitude she
doesn't care about anybody else she's
like almost there's some attitude there
you're like she's kind of not a nice
person you don't have to say who it is
there's three women
so none of them would know
was one of those kind of like yeah okay
there was one that I wouldn't
necessarily say that they were kind of
they weren't very rude they just were
very welcoming I'd like to say
uh so I just I think also too like I
could imagine it being your music video
with hundreds of people around all the
information in your head exactly so
that's why I don't take it personally
I'm like hey you know what we don't
wanna we don't have a conversation
that's totally fine yeah so Christina
Aguilera was probably just busy she
probably had uh a lot going on no I'm
kidding
um
laughs
Midnight Club yeah well you did this
movie in 2020 Pearl yes that looked like
it was it was a difficult role was it
not Pearl was my first full independent
movie yeah my first lead role so you
remember yes and it also had somebody
else in there Ming no one was in it who
was a friend of mine she was on the
podcast she was fantastic yeah she is
incredible what's so wild is I like
Bobby Roth the director like told me a
little bit about her and then when she
got there I I also like to like come
into things and I really not know so
much about people because it almost like
brings like this intimidation on you
know so I I was happy that I didn't
really like I knew she had been in a
couple things and she was just so kind
and just so humble that I was like then
after like reading like watched a bunch
of her work and I was like she's good
she is angry she's been incredible so
many things yes yeah she's great and
Anthony lopaglia yeah was he cool
um do you still talk to him yes you do
yeah but he was the I think I'm like so
grateful that being my
uh my first you know bigger role in a
film being with him was just what he
taught me and I know there was I
remember there was this one day where it
was a pretty emotional scene and I was
like putting so much pressure on myself
of like it has to be per here the whole
Perfection thing it has to be perfect
like I want to do great I want to give
my all like this is like the first take
and I'm just putting so much added
pressure on myself so we do this the
take the first take and
he comes down he pulls me aside he's
like you are putting way too much
pressure on yourself
holy crap he's like shake that off good
for him and I was like he's like Larson
you're like coming into this wanting to
start sobbing crying that is not what
you like you wouldn't just come up to me
like you're like at a birthday party
around a ton of people it wouldn't you
as your own person wouldn't just come up
like sobbing crying like it would just
be over time something that develops and
most of the time you're trying not to
cry that's the key so why are you trying
to come into this ball and crying he's
like quit it that is genius yes because
I've this helped me early on yeah
someone said
human beings
we don't want to cry yeah we do
everything not to cry yes so as an actor
you have to think I'm supposed to cry in
this scene and you're like I don't want
to do this I don't want to do this blah
blah and it's just and it's and it comes
out yeah and you're like [__] I don't
want this deck and so that's if you play
with that totally that was the answer
wasn't it yes and literally I remember
that the next take I just came into it
being like don't cry like don't like it
and I it was like I felt so great about
I just like came out like hugged him
after were you like going love packaged
no seriously but I'm just really I'm
really grateful for him and what he
taught me through those three months and
just like leading me and knowing it was
like my first
thing and just like it was really a
really cool
I have never met him but I love him yeah
regardless gosh he's an incredible
person so it was it was a really good
first experience because that could have
been tough yeah you could have been
working I'm glad you didn't work with an
insecure actor yeah whose ego and people
are weird about things oh she's prettier
than I am or she's this I have to be I'm
gonna be a [__] I'm gonna be really
that could really affect you especially
early on and the fact that you had two
supportive people there have your back a
good environment you're lucky yeah
you're very lucky and I'm happy that it
was a good experience yeah because it's
not always that I don't know how many
actors how many actors I've worked with
not not a ton but people who you go oh
man I just thought they were
I was hoping they'd be cool they're not
cool
[Music]
um It's usually the really big stars who
are cool
and the people who want to be famous who
are like right there like think they
have something to prove yeah so usually
those guys it
it's very interesting come as I've
started to work more in acting and just
seeing I think the dynamic of how you're
treated as an actor on sets and
it's very interesting because I did the
same kind of thing in dance but was
treated completely different but he went
there like do this do this you're going
too high like no water just like you're
you know you're stuck in a green room
with just like chairs as an actor you're
like guided on set every day like in
your trailer like you're just treated
lost and would you like a cookie yes and
with extra cookies from breakfast no
in these 80s they come up there like
Larson what can I give I'm like hey I
got two feet I'll go get my lunch don't
worry about it like I'll go you'll
remember that I'll go walk and get it
please like if you're doing enough and I
think I've
seen and become more grateful for that
coming from dance and being treated
almost working more hours than I am in
acting I think even harder in dancing
and just being treated completely
different You're Gonna Change
I hope no here's the thing this is gonna
happen for a while you're a really good
person you're gonna be this but like
after a while I'm always nice nah I'm
never mean I'm never but sometimes I'm
like
Greg
I love you what do you want I asked
could you get me a sandwich
uh just just a little mustard and turkey
that's it you know
I like you know oh my God I do the same
thing I like I don't want to always go
get my shoes you made it to a certain
point where you're like hey people are
here to help out and make your day
easier so you could be better so it's
not like you're you know you're an
[__] as long as you're a kind person
and yeah you want they want you know you
want people to like you I have that
problem I want everybody to like me so I
don't want to be a dick but you know uh
hey what do you want for breakfast
Michael I'm not gonna be like oh I can
go do that no yes they're asking me uh
you know I'm in makeup I I don't want to
get up totally yeah no I definitely do
I'm just saying like from the difference
of what I've seen I know just the way
that you get treated it's so sad it's
just like but I think that's almost
where the ego comes in in acting you
know what I mean when you are
everything's just kind of like here you
go here you know what I think it feels
like kind of eat that up yes you go
swells and they're like where's my this
um
I was gonna say
have you ever
yelled at someone yes
who have you yelled at
I feel that a lot of people might are
you a loud Yeller I'm a pretty loud
Yeller are you like like conviction like
you
don't ever do that again yeah
give me your best yell saying don't ever
do that again don't ever do that
all right Jason can we can we do
something with that that was pretty good
all right let's just hit that on a
replay really quick do me a favor do it
again back a little bit no I'm kidding
you know well if it's a [__] what I have
to I have to prepare sir [__] that was
loud Jason no you even have earmuffs on
that's a good Yeller by the way if I was
dating you and you yelled at me like
that I'd be oh my gosh so I think it's
reward a yellow pumps out very you have
to yeah
no but back to like what I was saying
growing up like my family if there's a
problem or somebody walks in like with
their head down and there's something on
their chest my parents will be the first
people to be like what is it like open
it up right like let's let's talk let's
sit at the table let's get into the the
good stuff and figure out why you're
acting the way you are
so I'm like grateful for that in a lot
of ways but some people come over and
it's very like wow your family's very uh
loud sometimes or it's they're very
emotional sometimes and but also very
warm engaging
I feel like
my parents never let people spend the
night I never really could have friends
over I hated I resented them for that I
always stayed at my friend's house as I
was always there they welcomed me it was
fun my grandmother her house was open
everybody my friend Carrie who and so
um I love that you have a family that
you could just go in and be comfortable
like I feel like I could already go into
your house and just plop on the couch
and go Elizabeth grab me a root beer
she would or she said get your damn self
that's probably what you say uh Midnight
Club yes Mike Flanagan created wrote If
you don't know him Haunting of Hill
House Oculus uh hush it goes on and on
he's amazing he's a kind soul he's super
talented
um Dr sleep what was it like working
with Mike Lanigan
did you have any of those big monologues
no oh my God yeah some people have that
yes were they scared yes he has those
and it's one of the reasons why I don't
I'm too scared to work with him right
now like I don't I can't learn a
three-page monologue yeah that's
terrifying yeah I won't get through it
not three pages I'll go I'll get through
a half page and then we'll you know then
I'll just go okay what's the line and
then you'll have about three cutaways
that's it but what was he like
um Mike video no so it's very Mike is
like you said he is just the most warm
kind he is he's just such a grounded
individual and he like it just Bloom it
made me enjoy the experience and enjoy
working with him even more just seeing
what a great person he is but I think
something I love is just how clear his
vision is and how that shines through in
the way that he directs us as acting he
knows what he wants he knows what he
wants and that was really great working
with somebody like that who would just
come up and be like hey Larson try it
like this and then I'd be like oh you're
right I didn't even like think of doing
it like that let's do it let's just try
it and I love like the so for the
Midnight Club most of the um within the
group of kids it was some of them their
first project and so I remember we did
like a uh at our table read the first
and during like prep the first two weeks
Mike took us through and just basically
like
showed us walked through basically
everything you'll need to know to be an
actor on set and did anybody get fired
from the table read no okay keep going
yeah
and I'll just I really enjoyed that and
I think it was like very helpful that
what I love about him too is the fact
that he gives people a chance you know
what I mean Mike isn't he wants to see
you shine yes and he's very just
welcoming and made it everyone feel so
comfortable like he's so experienced and
everyone was just like learning what to
do for the first time and he was like
Hey for the first take do what you've
practiced second take have you know have
some fun with it third take do whatever
you want let's just lose everything lose
everything you've lose everything you've
set up in your mind and the choices
you've made and it was always like that
yeah like that's how it always should be
that's what I always say reading how
it's written first second thing if we
got it then we're gonna go ever just try
something yes um did you work with my
good buddy Robert Longstreet no I don't
think it's working he played the janitor
no I haven't seen it yet I'm gonna watch
it yeah I haven't seen it yet do you do
any um accents by the way or uh
Impressions no you can't do any
Impressions I mean dialects I really
need to work on my British accent oh I'm
not that's the one thing I'm I could do
a better Australian I think Hmm path
Adelaide Sydney
and my family's all from Melbourne
do you ever go there never been it's
awesome oh I want to go so bad it's
awesome I've been there a couple times
Robert Long Street uh he was the janitor
at Midnight Club for two episodes let me
see he is this you'll know him oh yeah
watch this dude
okay no so I didn't meet
was he good yes he's always good I mean
what I love about the Midnight Club is
it's very which I'm very sad it didn't
get picked up for a second season but
you know were you surprised yeah I was a
little bit surprised I think it's that
was too because everything Flanagan does
it goes yeah yeah and I I think though
the the message even within the first
season is just so well done and I think
it you know it explores life and death
Through The Eyes of young kids I love
the concept and it's just the way that
Christopher bike and actually reading up
the story behind how the Midnight Club
came to be for Christopher [__] like a
mother of um her daughter who was very
sick reached out to him with cancer and
said that they would meet and like talk
about Christopher Christopher Pike's
books at night so she said can you write
a book about us and that's how the
Midnight Club came to be and I'm like
wow that is just so incredible and then
the way that Mike just you know through
all the stories how each you know story
feeds into the past of the characters or
you know feeds their own character
development was just so well well done
like I just am blown away like being
able to see the whole thing because I
didn't get to work with the seven kids
directly I'm playing back in the 60s
young Samantha and so I didn't get to
act with them um as a group so being
able to watch the series straight
through and see them as a unit and gosh
my friend Ruth Cod she just blew me away
really and her backstory she was found
off Tick Tock and so talk about like how
things have changed it's just like isn't
that amazing back in the day
if you did TV you couldn't do film hmm
and film people snobs I'm not doing TV
wow and now everybody wants to do TV yes
everybody wants to do a series stream
you name one person who doesn't Kevin
Costner's doing it everybody does it
yeah Helen mirren's doing a new like
series or some [__] that's so wild so it
was like Harrison Ford yeah so if it was
like if you're in TV you can do what you
want now yeah do YouTube fine or YouTube
Star great yes let's do it yeah
um this is called [__] talking with
Larson Thompson these are rapid fire
these are questions from my top tier
patrons I love them they support the
podcast it truly helps us go to
patreon.com inside of you and I'll send
you a message here we go
laughs
I think she's laughing out I just love
seeing your Expressions each time I look
over he'll be like
Allison are you laughing at me or with
me I'm laughing with you I love to laugh
good yeah hang around us
that's also why people enjoy my company
with everybody no great I just am very
you get I can I laugh very easily so
people I think like to have me around
because it makes them think they're
which you are funny but like if you want
to feel funny just have me around for
the day because I will laugh really
I like that because you know I always
say I want someone that could enjoy
things that
I really enjoy like
don't laugh at me folks listeners but I
uh I like going to the mall sometimes my
friend Sharon I'll go shopping we'll
have a coffee we'll sit on a Brookstone
massage thing
I love them all I like going doing
stupid stuff shopping going to whatever
I almost lose the inner child no
what but you're doing an impression and
I'm trying to think of what it was oh
see this what is this what am I doing
I don't know I wasn't doing walking I
could do it if you want I think they're
probably tired of me doing it
uh Kelly s how was it like working with
Heather langenkamp oh
there you go nightmare oh Elm Street yep
well she signed my poster I hope so go
ahead oh Heather so Heather and I didn't
get to work directly with one another we
met but we met the nicest she is so
sweet she gave me a hug like the first
time we met and just like a total dream
she sat at like our table read when we
were like giving an introduction for how
to basically be an actor on set and she
was like acting as if she's learning
everything for the first time too I'm
just like you are like did you have her
sign anything no little Lee so what was
it like what was the last TV show you
binged watched oh the last year oh gosh
I watched you watch Dahmer so dark oh my
Lord oh you know what I'm watching I'm
binging right now no For All Mankind on
Apple TV
probably one of my favorite shows of all
time
I remember trying to start at night okay
so yeah the first three episodes
very it's hard it gets great
just get through the first three
episodes and then it's one of those
right
that's the story the show wired they
talk about that show they're like one of
the best shows ever made I'm like I
watch two episodes and I could not sit
through it and they're like you just
have to get through like three or four
and then it's brilliant and I'm like oh
Lord kind of like White Lotus I was like
I don't want to watch anybody I don't
it's just I don't know and I kept
watching and watching and then at the
end it got better yeah but I was like
you know I don't want to watch five
episodes I don't care about but people
love it I get it I I don't know I like I
didn't hate it I'd say yeah watch it you
should definitely watch it yeah yeah but
I just it's I don't know I just wasn't
I'll never do that no I think I want you
to watch it because the acting too is
just phenomenal all right Jackie r
favorite role you've played so far
favorite role I played so far
probably I've really enjoyed Julia Jane
in the Midnight Club the nightclub just
being able to play those flashbacks to
be in the 60s I've like always wanted to
do period what's your favorite 60s song
oh God just walk away Renee
no no no no no I think it's 60s yeah I
don't know you don't know that one la la
la la la la la la la la la
but there was one time we were playing
when I was on set that day and I'm like
I can't remember it yeah from the 60s
and I was like I could live in this era
I think I was meant to live in this era
Maya P what would you be doing now if
you weren't acting or dancing probably
playing soccer
well you can't do that for a living
hey you could you have neck problems no
it's too late to start no but if I
hadn't been dancing I wouldn't have
gotten the neck problem
good I Like It song okay so soccer
player I'm not gonna crush your dreams
if you weren't doing your dreams now
yeah I'm dream crushing right now a
little bit sorry no it's all right okay
Raj last questions tell me tell me a
personal sacrifice you feel you've had
to make to pursue a career in the
entertainment industry
wow can I can I guess yeah sure
it's hard to be away from your family
and it's like for the first time you're
actually away doing different things and
you miss them
yeah
what else no I I like that's pretty
great because it is it's very isolating
sometimes like just being away for three
months six months filming something and
you're just like I'm very close to my
family I have a hard time being alone
and it is part of the job thankfully
like my parents can come out and like
visit which they haven't yet you know
bastards
um
have you ever had a beer
no have you ever had vodka no have you
ever had an alcoholic beverage wine in
Greece did you like it no did you throw
up
no I didn't but I my parents are were
this is the story they drink no so my
parents are actually
22 years sober
well that makes there you go that makes
perfect sense yeah so you don't wanna
it's in the blood maybe exactly you
don't want to do that yeah
funny my parents were never big drinkers
yeah I never was worried about being
addicted to the alcohol
never had that addiction Ryan
me yeah no you drink I do not a lot my
parents live in Wine Country so there's
wine on the country yeah this has been a
real treat
this has been a treat thank you guys so
much I was I was hoping you never laugh
and that you were just laughing because
you wow this is funny stuff no you made
it very clear abundantly clear no I'm
kidding I'm joking with you I don't I I
really enjoy this and I'll be honest
with you can I be completely open I
talked to Ryan or like yeah look I don't
know Larson yeah uh she doesn't have a
big body of work yet she's you know just
growing and she's she's great and she's
but I I don't know I'm like how do what
angle what is there you know because I
like to just and it was so easy to just
free just with that free base what's a
free Jesus no what is it called just
start something and then continue
talking free form free form free flow it
was just you were so easy to talk to you
had storage you had things about your
life you're proud of who you are you're
proud of your family it was uh
refreshing you know it's it's refreshing
to sometimes not hear about
you know
um because this industry can weigh on
you and you know people get into drugs
people getting alcohol people get into
there's a there's a lot of bad things
out there and the fact that you haven't
been affected by that and you're in this
business and you're pretty grounded it
makes me really happy it makes me have
hope
for the world and and and young people
whatever you know just
you're not that young enough like you're
15 but I'm just saying yeah you know
what I mean I appreciate that yeah thank
you so keep doing what you're doing
thank you don't forget the little people
oh come on well come on I've heard that
before
I mean there's people that I I you know
no we'll be sitting here 10 years from
now yeah and I'll be like what was it
like
beating up Meryl Streep in that scene
and you're like ah you know it was hard
because I don't really like
um you know um
hitting or you know no I actually do I
enjoy all that stuff the grungy stuff oh
boy where I can like be beating people
up oh why don't we why don't we talk
about that
you know what's also cool is when you
lashed out a minute ago whether Jason
cuts it or not she she screamed and it
might be it might have been too loud for
the mic but maybe it's in there I don't
know but
it was funny because the contrast I I
saw you you're able to you're able to
turn on the dime you're able to just go
Frick off
yeah
thanks for being on the podcast thanks
for allowing me to be inside of you in
the podcast and uh it was a real treat
Ryan did you have a good time great time
yeah a lot of refreshing
interview
yeah see you guys see ya
oh wait wait what's your handle Larson
Thompson at at Larson Thompson on
everything not Thompson Larson like
Michael well it's not ad you can just
give away your email did you no okay
good yeah like because you said at no
like Instagram handle at Larson Larson
with an E Larson not oh like a grandma
Yeah and um anything brewing coming up
I'm but you have the horror movie
horoscope yes that comes January 23. if
you're horror fans like me you better be
looking for that yes and I'm actually
launching My First Single in music are
you Larson Thompson it's just Larson
Thompson yeah
well you know I want to hear some of
your stuff I have a band called Sun spin
I know you do yes how do you know that
because I knew that oh good keep
watching thanks
wonderful human being it was a joy to
have her on uh full of life I mean a lot
of people I'm sure you don't know her or
didn't know her and um I think uh she's
such a good spirit and she got Anthony
lapaglia he's coming on the podcast she
worked with him and I've been emailing
with him and he said yeah come on the
podcast cool so she was really cool to
help me out with that cool cool all
right um thank you for listening
um and uh inside of you uh
uh inside of your online store go there
great merch like I talked about in the
beginning if you can hear about it also
sunspin my band sunspin the album is out
streaming everywhere please listen to it
downloaded put it on Spotify support the
band Sun spin the new album is never as
what it is it's uh you know what I never
do this Ryan
what are you gonna play a sunspin song
you never do that
I really don't do I very rarely well
it's been a while
and it's been a while remember that song
all right this is the song the theme
song from uh stained from uh talk Ville
have a listen if you haven't heard it
[Applause]
when I'm with you I just don't feel at
home
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
all right there you go nice pretty cool
yeah yeah I really love that song it's
What are we here for so download it
please you also buy to see CD on
sunspin.com and a ton of other cool
merch and get a zoom with me and Rob it
also feels like uh it belongs in the
trailer for an indie movie that's what I
think yeah kind of like a 50 years of
Summer yeah what was it movie called oh
uh 500 Days of Summer yeah like an
Anthem I was picturing Mark duplos
running through a field or something
yeah yeah I I love it so we're working
on trying to get placement and stuff and
that's always hard but uh we'll see what
happens but most importantly we're proud
of it and we accomplished this and uh I
urge you to go follow your dreams and
your passions thanks for listening we're
gonna do the the major components
integral parts of this podcast
the top tier patrons here we go
Nancy D Leah asked Sarah V little Lisa
Yukiko Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert B
Jason W selfie aim roll C
Joshua di Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B
Mikey Eldon Supremo 99 more Santiago M
Gary Oldman
Chad w
ien p
I have to get into it
when you're dealing with an industry
like this you have to have a great ego
and Sam and
Francis Ford Coppola has [__] the size
of San Francisco
Leanne P to Nina Maya P Maddie s Belinda
n Dave H Sheila G Brad D rage
Rey Rey had a baby happy baby Ray Raby
I'm so proud of you and happy thank you
for being such an amazing Patron and
person and uh we all love you
happiness and healthyness Tabitha tea
Tom how are you Thomas a Talia and Betsy
do you haven't talked to you in a while
good Lord Chad B Dan and Angel M
Rhiannon C Cory K Deb Nixon Michelle a
Jeremy C Brandy D Camille ask Joey M
Eugene and Leah
you should put Eugene and Leah and the
baby's name forgot the baby's name
wasn't Lex was it uh Corey Heather L
Jake B Megan T Angela F Mel s Orlando C
Caroline R Christy s Christine s sorry
Eric h
I'm not a drink of water I wish you
would
shaynar Emma R Andrew M zaduichi 77
Andreas and Oracle Karina and hi Karina
Amanda R Jenny B gen B Kevin e Stephanie
K Jarrell Jim and Jay Leanne J
jamming with jam and Jay Leanne J
Luna R Cindy e Mike F Stone h
Stonehenge just remember Stonehenge I
just remember a spinal tap steinange
it's steinange steinange
steinange and the people of Stein and
the people of Stone Age
Mike S Brian L Katie B Aaron R Kendall L
House of Joe L Joe E Joel House of
Joelle Meredith I Professor Dr scoots
Prof doctor scoots hi doctor scoots how
are you Charlene C kerosey Mary R Kyle F
Marisol p
could not do the podcast without you
period the end I will not ramble on
about it it's just the damn truth thank
you for joining if you're not a patreon
please join and join the fun
um thanks for listening guys I love you
from Michael Rosenbaum here in the
Hollywood Hills California
a little wave to the camera we love you
guys thank you and of course
um be good to yourself please I'll see
you next week
[Music]